[Music]
oh yeah thanks Sindel for screaming
right when I do the intro what's up
everybody a prayer to hear John Luke is
joining me and this Wednesday is kind of
like our Friday here in the office so
we're doing a little bit of like a
community Friday mashup thing today and
yeah we're playing a mortal kombat xi
candelas out so I know a lot of people
were really excited for her I also
obviously heard people who were like
what did you do to her but I think she
looks pretty cool all her variations are
really interesting and I'm gonna rely on
you guys to tell me her actual lore that
people are so upset about because I
don't really know Oliver more but I did
hear that her story is a bit different a
bit yeah okay interesting yeah you know
how that goes close backstory about time
travel line so I think it's fine but I
guess I can understand that I haven't
seen her yet so I'm really excited to
see her in action yes so she has
obviously three different tournament
variations I've been mostly using the
Empress of evil one because it seems
pretty simple which is when I have
equipped right now so I guess like
weekend she goes like this little
Sakura's fireball this one kind of like
VP there it looks like a DP
the amplify cancel that and then do more
and of course if you are on Twitter then
you can definitely find an endless sea
of videos and combos already out of here
because that's just what the fgc does
best they get these new characters and
they break them immediately
so yeah I probably won't linger around
too much in training modes right now how
you guys are you want to see some action
just don't be disappointed when I don't
really have that great of kamma
of combos and what not which is cool
stuff so she has like this hair command
throw here and makes me work in the air
also and then she has like cool stuff
off this where you do like you know an
air-to-air kick into that which I kind
of learned it's like preschool to me
so yeah this this mode is pretty cool
she also has like her three move you
charge it up and fully charges the
blockable or just like staggers state
could do some cool things and then yeah
I her normal we don't seem bad at all
she's got some pretty good streams like
this little booty bump one is only
negative for on block I think if they're
blocking high if they're blocking
crouching it doesn't connect and then
obviously you have to get another
overhead one that does hit if you're
crouching so some interesting tools so
far her other variations she has like a
projectile which is pretty cool I'll
just show it to you guys real quick
before we hop into matches and you know
if you guys know me you know I don't
play MK that much so there's still a lot
of things I'm getting used to in this
game in general like this cool
projectile which can actually
low-profile under a lot of other pieces
projectiles there's been a thing I've
noticed recently and then if that one to
amplify it like a beam and knocks it
down a little soft knockdown type action
um so yeah ooh actually seeing someone
in chat seeing her new lure is amazing
so shout outs to you curious yeah I
definitely I've heard a lot of
back-and-forth of things but yeah oh
yeah euphemism in the chat kind of
elaborating more on
these two strings here that I was
telling you guys about +3 yeah I
remember that string being uh pretty
good pretty good
so yeah um I'm working on like an hour
one Sindel here so that's why not
you know just jump straight into matches
right right I don't know we're gonna do
it though so ok if you guys want to play
do they have a lot they have lobbies
which late lobby down here before let's
see if we can start up a lobby lobbies
are excellent in this game because I've
been getting under people oh oh yeah
that was something they added after it
be initial one right or was that on
launch - I do remember people being like
you have a hundred people in the song I
think that was that watch custom lobby
noise king of the hill that might be
nice might be able to see you guys play
a little bit two against each other
competitive mode oh okay you know what
I'm gonna turn that on
ah alright so oh just kidding now you
gotta make that yeah you did a private
one that's why oh I say go down
all right so we are making a room we are
gonna name it
[Music]
GS m'kay that's good
nice and easy yeah alright that is the
lobby here we get up let's see it lets
see oh so now we just wait for you guys
I think exactly cool so Lobby is up it's
open
GS m'kay if you need any other details
aside from that let me know but yeah I
think we're good
euphemism dropping the Sindel knowledge
in the chat already saying interestingly
if you execute it as soon as you can do
it to scream cancel is +2 unblocked oh
yeah that's something else I've been
seeing floating around in the Twinner
twitter universe is that she has all the
scream cancel shenanigans and it
actually makes a lot of her normals and
other things much more safe than they
would be without the cancel correct me
if I'm wrong even ISM but those cancels
definitely require meter but obviously
worth it if you're gonna be trying to go
for some some okie or just you don't
want to keep yourself generally safe and
it looks like we have someone in the
chat right now I mean in the lobby right
now
excellent so yeah go ahead I've seen
this person before nice welcome
they have hopped in when me and Ben have
done community Fridays with Mortal
Kombat so nice to see you back yes
welcome back zy Skywalker let's uh force
some competitive action
alright should be a good time
like I said Sindel my Sindel super fresh
I know maybe one combo but we're gonna
we're doing it we are in there see if I
could just rely on my fundamental
[Music]
alright here we go
oh damn and we got Skywalker in the chat
what up what up
alright so my first ever match against a
real person with Shindell oh geez I
forgot there is most definitely a block
button that's hello oh that's an
overhead oh this is already going so bad
Oh
all right we got this Oh too far it's
somehow black that oh nice and the booty
bump oh I got one of those too Bing oh
dang tried to scream at her let's ride
the block button really gets me every
time
[Applause]
yep
very nice oh yeah I have to uh I have to
find our hair fatality is all right good
first match GG soon they'll definitely
have some cool stuff like I really liked
that little hair command throw she has
where she like flips over you good
Brendan's asking if this could be a
podcast on Friday yes we recorded one a
little bit early yesterday and it will
be up on Friday at the usual time noise
noise not even Thanksgiving roll jump
one is my main jumping combo starter ok
ok ok gotcha
I will try to keep that in mind
Oh spinning all the bars that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
scream at ER you're right you're right I
need to scream or need to use the vocal
cord
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay okay
yes LuAnn I don't remember what it is
I'll just do this alright guys dumping
what some point I said was done that yet
and I got a scream more but I think her
hair commands I could warm it up yeah
get into it slowly but surely let's see
if anyone else is in the air yeah
it's one one gonna be fair okay run back
[Applause]
Oh
oh man you got real waggy all of sudden
after I got that first game you can mr.
Zanger looking for a conversion your
best make sense named two swords
Oh No jumpin
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness oh and then the heels and
the eyes all right all down to this I
know I forgot blackness
Oh Barney right view of that let's go
all right I'm gonna go find out with
that fatality is one of you babe the
second all fighting games can figure out
how to master lag we are set we are that
is will be the best time to be alive
hi Gigi Gigi is nice two out of three
I'm sorry Jamie I don't know the
fatality I'm girl looking up right now
just so I can have it on deck for if I
ever get another chance we've got
someone else here oh snap the homie from
Vegas what up oh wait what just happened
what does happen to our screen Oh
again we won't get back in there in a
moment
there we go there we go Oh finicky down
there alright let's see I'm just gonna
see if I can okay here we go
I found the notations excellent I will
try to keep them on deck for next time
all right
so whoops wait hold on let me try that
again got a horse a competitive mode
Sindel got a match praise the fighting
game lords for letting me fight
underwater that way all right - cancel -
three man you're really laying the tech
on me heavily here Baraka I'm about to
get it shanked
[Laughter]
yes back forward back square down down
forward one those are pretty easy to
remember actually some of them have a
lot of inputs
once it gets like four or more inputs
before you press a button I'm like whoa
boom all right let's see
I'd like try to do my little commander
totally jump into it oh I forgot to pull
the button sorry
I mean you won't have that moving
forward and I'm still alive it's so hard
to jump over four decks out of the game
ninety-four
[Applause]
ding
oh that go pretty far
oh very good job my hair whip Oh back
towards one or a backward one yeah
you're right guys do you say word
doesn't go super viral but it definitely
has some like hit confirm properties
that are nice it's so hard to jump over
projector work
[Applause]
crap
gotta throw up in
No
you can get the run back yeah yeah it's
just got a hmm oh you know what forward
I'm not using forward for it now forward
for is pretty in it's my little spinny
kick I'm a little cartwheel Barack is a
strong cat Brock ervil's vs. Wolverine
man Wolverine would destroy Baraka right
don't disrespect my boy will be like
that where he's got the healing rocketed
I try to play
No
with my butt
I like actually can't even jump up
whoa I don't know what happened there
but we take it very short
ah or what's forward
I kind of feel like me as a player I
need I don't know how I can survive in
this pain without a projectile
especially we can jump over them
teleport oh yeah not quite
more it's like she has a slide
what up drill maybe the slides on a
different Oh a different variation right
I know she does a variation where she
has that little projectile oh shoot I
didn't want to rematch that was already
- yeah all right no more unofficial yeah
unofficial three out of five
now
I will use the block button and I forget
to search
I feel like I can be I'm just gonna spam
this projectile
[Applause]
Hey Dude combo let's go how about you
I'm ready for this vacation oh yeah
feelin it people in the chat planning
anything fun for Thanksgiving long
weekend
oh man Napa what hey
oh my gosh you can always pick the left
unless you guys I'll be great if you did
hold that
oh wait back forward back down down
forward yeah I have to read it off the
screen in time let's go you already know
let's go all right I got excited there
first for a moments
good job thank you thank you my little
hair throw though it's pretty clutch if
you ask me a Stargate fighting game I
almost feel like every single like me
being that exists could be turned into a
fighting that's true all right straight
deathclaw what's up homie silly the jam
he'll why not i play king of the hill
fighting game GG Brandon Hernandez was
fun he was definitely slicing me up I
[Laughter]
think if you like me to bring that move
he just stabs you for like ten times
longer all right but yes Gigi's snuck in
that last match
so zero
I want to be cold
Oh hair flip and haircut a holiday dang
bummer
one day online all right we gotta make a
new room you guys that's Sub Zero is
biting me so hard the whole server
collapse it was like we are not having
this online all right looks like and do
it GS MK 11
aren't you the server rage quit on us
alright alright we made a new we made a
new room it is G s MK 11
please join back up it's always happens
with MK I don't know why every time you
been play always happens I don't know if
it's the game if it's his room we're
just cursed we're cursed but we have a
new one up so please feel free to join
again yeah there we go he's back is that
the one you were fighting yes excellent
excellent combat pact only 20 bucks good
deal for all the DLC characters and you
get to play DLC early which is also a
bonus Sindel is actually only available
right now to everyone who has combat
pack but it's not available to everybody
else until December 3rd
they're like $5.99
my characters live in now I think it's
been a pretty good amount
all right back at it staged brutality
using a lion I do not know that one
there's so many
all right back at it oh man all
readiness man everybody wakes up with
that
oh I play the back - movement is so
clunky in this game that's crazy that
that moves have so much pushback oh
sorry guys I'm working off an hour once
in dollar right now but it's all good
it's all good
FTC Linux says am I the only MK playing
around sick I'm playing on stick right
now although I do not know if it's
actually the most effective way to play
only because after about like an hour my
pinky gets so sore from holding down the
block button it feels like the game
really was designed more for a pad yeah
even though what but if you remember
like the old score arcade cabinets the
button layout was all funky like
specifically designed - yeah
throws are so hard to break in the same
that's an overhead
[Music]
[Music]
does the screen make projectiles vanish
that's actually a good question I can
try it try it next time you throw some
ice at me see if I can do it
jason says get over hair Britain so as I
can with go girls I know I'm gonna try
to get a stick for the switch so we can
play on there
[Music]
Yashin neutral Oh No yeah I like the man
Cruz won our game was so close to Xing
come on servers what's worse is like you
have to make the whole lobby again it
doesn't just send you back and uh even
if you can like fine the lobby and it
just doesn't yes I should be a different
name every change the name every time
sorry dude that's like the second time
in our alright s MK 1 1 1 an extra
there's just an extra one in there
alright
fast forward a couple hundred years
we're on MK 111 man would it really be
like that you know like years you're
like hundred years down the line though
they'll still remember when we were on
Mortal Kombat 50 now we're on Mortal
Kombat 111
I can't imagine that I'm sure I'm trying
to picture anything lasting that long
man I can't we have a new wow 2338 winds
yacht yeah I don't like my odds either
I'll tell you that
alright so uh let's do it
yeah I feel like even way back in the
day oh okay we're gonna have a real
Sindel player he's using the one with
the projectile which I'm stirred I'm
about to get shot up yeah I remember way
back in the day like when he was out and
hey like we were waiting for Halo 3 and
we're like yeah you know when we rolled
gonna be playing like hey oh thank you
for the reassurance although I still
think you'll be better than than I am oh
my gosh I love this skin also oh my gosh
it's so pretty I have to let her intro
rock just like I see it some more you
have to like go and unlock those in the
game also she can do stuff out of that
stance actually wasn't sure she could
oh my gosh I forgot the follow-up I
think I hope well sit down is down good
wow that's a little that's awesome
ouch what single player games are we
playing right now actually did go by ooh
oh man I forgot already that was alone
[Applause]
oh right to Xena definitely does
I bought the late news mystery adventure
game cuz I'm like a huge latent but I
had never actually gotten around to
playing that one definitely different
making my way through that's driving oh
nice
fan I want to play Disko Elysium I've
heard it's about out of ten I know I'm
like I have to play it now what the fuss
is about video producer Jake Decker was
saying it's one of the favorite game
[Music]
oh I forgot oh yeah I'm not sure if this
match is casual or competitive but I did
see use like throwing a projectile out
of the fly stands and I was like yeah
yeah cuz so far all the tournament
stamps as I've seen I haven't seen any
moves you can do out of that except for
just cancelling
oh my gosh I'm trying to do the highball
of instead of the low I think it's that
one there we go oh man 3/4
[Applause]
ah
no really
[Applause]
oh yeah I still don't know how to break
throws other brutality oh oh the other
one this time nice that's good good yeah
I like seeing some more matchup sucks
okay have a good happy turkey day miss
so wholesome
I like sigh it's rare I feel like you
play online and then the praising is
actually really nice to you all right
who's next who's nice close in Lobby its
imitate 111 in case you guys forgot wait
I gotta make sure you guys are all I
actually accepted it I think too late I
was like I gotta make sure y'all are
playing on tournament variations it's
all good it's fine it doesn't matter one
three or two oh thank you euphemism
spreading the knowledge on how to uh
break throws gotcha okay yeah
I just remember it had to be like if
there's growing if they hit me with a
forward throw I have to tech with the
forward throw option and then vice versa
so no I kind of wanted him to pick the
one with the ghost like sandals cuz you
could do all these really cool fancy
like ghost combos which are really
really fun picking someone else changing
their mind
go back and sit down don't let your
dreams be dreams these are just casuals
with a case so you can play whoever you
want I was like writing the title in the
deck for the stream today and like on my
Mac I have its where it still
autocorrects so all of my combats with a
K we're getting autocorrected to the
seed no like no I can't let this go live
like this oh I'm a different color I see
oh oh I definitely pressed the button
oh look hounds I'm gonna see all these
moves in slow motion action whoa whoa
all the booty to the favorite I love it
that's a good air-to-air confirm oh whoa
[Music]
that didn't hit her that is shenanigans
[Music]
oh no I'd rather grab it worked
yeah ding yes okay its back forward back
square yeah all right you can see the
other one the same thank you google for
giving me all this oh yes this is a real
reason why I grow my hair out cuz one
day I'm gonna do [ __ ] good lord
I am definitely gonna try to go to combo
breaker next year for shellfish oh I
feel like combo breaker is one of the
one of the events you have to go to as
fighting game player every year you know
it was pretty obvious back in the day it
was like yeah Evo CEO of a combo breaker
combo breakers up there shouts the Rick
and Kat the organizer is holding it down
whoa that was an accident all right for
tonight go is like all right no more
games
I'm gonna hit you with the realness oh
he's about to call all the aminals out
he's pretty cool too I've seen a lot of
cool night wolf players sniffing some
real cool things with my Walters
[Laughter]
where are you from euphemism you say
it's an eight-hour flight to Chicago
that is pretty far oh man oh man oh oh
my goodness the fact that you can jump
[Music]
over Stalin
oh dang all right so it's 1:1 yeah it
gets a tiebreaker in there I'll burn
instantly miss Foster hundred Friday's
oh uh
it'll definitely I will definitely hop
back in when the PC version comes out
for sure nice oh that's gonna be
beautiful
yeah it's been so busy this this fall we
were hoping to maybe do a we did once
when the expansion came high-scoring
hoping to double side it has been just
crazy this this fall
I'm gonna try out one of her other
variations here I feel like I need some
help I need some projectiles I don't
know how to live without it
Oh Aaron black I really like it I know
it's funny how you even like those
characters like screen is like
struggling it's like so I'm trying to
think I have the projectile I have like
one from the air also which is pretty
cool I can remember what it is alright
No
I want that move with you better than
although the lag
oh I thought I was gonna go under I
should have just did my my potato blows
here I was thinking about it now you got
your saved crazy
honey no dang it
what'll combat VR game that sounds too
much oh I tried to use my fatal blow I
was I already took my hands off the
screen yeah you know fighting is me so
much better internet connection was
always flawless
I feel like that's probably the only
thing holding back like fighting games
from like being on the same level of
some of the other eSports is like people
do scrims and stuff for shooters and
like League of Legends and it's never a
problem
just hard it's alright it's Heartland
and fighting games you need like every
single input to be like on point yeah I
mean there's some games other games were
that's it's not as much of a problem
though yeah like a counter-strike I feel
like I need that precision yeah yeah
definitely
alright overwatch we're more lenient
yeah all right anybody else want to join
up we've currently played with everyone
in the lobby at the moment but if anyone
would like to give it a go or if John
Luke wants to play I'm not playing
why let's talk to 49 ghosts as we just
did them again right you ready to go
back to the Skywalk
oh I see someone else join in it and
explore what's up oh no he left for a
what we're gonna okay oh he's back back
please stay please accept their
challenge
yeah she has other cool stuff in that
variation I was just using right now too
that I wasn't really using I was using
the projectile mostly but she has like
this thing called royal trap and it
she's like summons an orb and if it's
close enough to the opponent it just
shoots out little projectiles it's
pretty cool that's why I already seen
people use it in combos use that one I
kind of wanted them to be used a loud
and clear variation and hoping they know
the cool combo I'm telling you guys that
combo is really how did that happen
fighting explore hacks the heck all
right sorry for it and I go take too
long and we already played against you
somehow yes that was some hacks right
there man is he still in here oh he's
playing again someone else now and he's
playing against another person who's new
man why you do this fortnight goats
we've got to give everyone a chance that
low fireball seems so polite it was
pretty cool it's kind of just nice to
have a projectile sometimes only cuz I'm
not you know super geta in case on my
movement isn't quite there and I feel
like a projectile helps balance that a
little bit but the real meat potatoes of
Sindel is not any of that it's
definitely her cancels their stance
controls which are super cool man I wish
I could show you guys some of these
combos they're really
[Music]
maybe that's why you put us in a
mattress someone else maybe they had
joined a match to get ready for tonight
go oh no no not your fault for there
yeah don't be sorry
we're just want to play with everything
yeah where it confused as to how did you
hack our servers no I'm just kidding but
all good for tonight goat and Zell Q
should play against each other I feel
like you guys would have fun facing off
while I take a brief intermission
collect my salt yo Ben in the chat what
is up in hey Ben are you enjoying I know
we busy at the office I'm gonna go on
Twitter and see if I can download some
tech from my Sindel while we wait for
explorer and rogue to finish their match
it's real out here sonic Fox posted a
combo and I was like dang this is what
it means to be good at this game
let's see if anybody else came up with
something now I think I think I'm
definitely feeling this variation though
but yeah man yeah it's like slight
cancel combos off of the jump - it's
like jump - she just the air scream you
can cancel into another jump - it's very
Marvel ask I will say that indeed
Michael Taylor says it's anybody
experience the server keeps crashing yes
it already crashed twice well we have
people in here what is going on
everybody
Marco ant oh he left alright alright
heartless your necks then while we wait
for everybody else is slack busy today
for you because I felt like there's
barely anyone in the office say I know
right
it's called vacation Ben what are you
doing waiting Jade she's cool one of my
best friends for life Cherise uses Jade
very cool character I can't remember use
that back three I think it's back there
yeah where is it forward three
ooh
[Music]
youthful ism and dropping the notations
for that combo which looks crazy even in
words
wow it's even crazier in video oh yeah I
think so I just to get away one thing I
really struggle with in this game is
like even though there's a black button
I'm still holding back when I'm walking
right and then I try to like walk
forward and do a move and I get back
forward which is like a special move
notation so I get the special move all
the time
oh such bad habits
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey I mash so hard to get that out I
have my buttons that's a really weird
configuration so the elf you are tuned
for that really weird right now it's all
good if I match I did enough I
eventually hit the bottom thing
yeah back forward back spur but oh I get
it yeah
I think wait okay that took a really
long time to start up so I wasn't sure
it was good I love me some falafel so
anytime we get a Mediterranean food or
anything halal relator anything that is
falafel I'm about it's good
I was low-key hoping there's leftovers a
lot of ones like take some oh nice
euphemus you feminists and my input
buffer link timing to shore in the
controls which I did not know is the
thing and yes you're totally correct I
should do that cuz I definitely have a
big issue with just getting a buffered
stuff on accident my help
ah
jumping stocks in this game I like this
heroin move but I cannot find the right
places to use it ever
the move is cheap for people like me who
don't hold the block button when they're
slow but you can't smack Black Friday
shopping I really thought about it to be
honest you know in my traffic oh I might
try and pick up a ring fit adventure hey
because people have been talking about
up is actually like a pretty decent way
to exercise
no oh that was an accident
[Music]
take your time getting up anyway and see
how many times I can little there we go
I was like I'm gonna let me do this a
lot freezing that that doesn't hippie by
the air like cheese does bummer I'm
trying to do like wha like blocking and
then just doing like back three and
getting the fly because I'm black and
sauce I'm like that too there was a one
one actually not remember I don't run
breather
[Laughter]
oh that came back too soon they'll do
one more one more one more one more
I wonder if you build to change your
controls in the lobby Oreo falls back
out that's a good question that's cool
that they made that an option I think
having longer windows oh my gosh no
scary what I did that
[Music]
ODS and overhead oh that's so cheap
definitely blocking that one but it was
it overhead of course by and came out
for $30 a week to all things different
all the DLC characters well I I'm
wondering when they'll actually do an
alternative issue because it's said on
Twitter that they're planning on
supporting the game for a really long
time which made it sound like they're
probably gonna have it to the knowledge
DLC characters so you might have to wait
a while if you're doing an ultimate
edition is but I guess it depends on if
you're really itching to play the game
now it's gonna play it now $30 is pretty
good you can get it for $30 and like you
said you can get
$50 you're getting everything all the
DLC characters let's that's not bad
anything that gives you the option at
least play some characters like yeah I'm
always down for a portal Clara Jake here
if you're itching to play the game now
about $30
[Music]
alright gg's oh I got a reward some time
crystals noise alright alright let's see
who else is in the lobby you know we
come for him yeah like 15 minutes left
of the stream GG's in the chat online
I like Jade though should be a gorge
she'd be pokin me let's play some good
oh he's challenged us even better even
better did I enjoy the new Star Wars
game um
I mean to be fair on xbox not that much
but PC is way better I had some straw
just weird things were happening
honestly like there was one part where I
had an objective to follow and it was
like you know had the objectives in go
over the plan now supposed to go to but
it wouldn't let me hover over it or
select it oh so I had to go to a
completely different planet first I went
to pagano first kind of like reset it
and when it landed the plane it had the
ramp like going off a completely like it
didn't even lay out where it was
supposed to land I was like what this is
crazy
but all the other times I went to poke
on it like landed correctly but that one
time I like walked out and the ramp just
leads straight off the cliff
like whoa man yeah I played on PC and I
didn't have any issues like that
you're bad though and then you know a
lot of general just like loading issues
sometimes the whole like half a cutscene
wouldn't even show up okay still loading
like things at least in my experience it
doesn't sound like there are some bugs
been overhead
smash it out for a second it's over
all right stuck with that string no I
should have just blocked I do is coming
I play it on the Xbox one s it's a
portal player asked
[Music]
oh it's for wings oh I keep messing up
this string oh the lag oh you dropped it
oh I tried to throw dang and lack at the
most
impromptu part of the whole thing
[Music]
scorpions good though he was the
character I was actually using or like
settled on when the game first came out
because I was like yeah he has a lot of
really good accessible like combos and
options and fifty fifties and he has a
lot of tricky stuff that don't really
like work requires too much like cancels
himself like that which I like in a
character so he's who I ultimately ended
up settling on because he was pretty
pretty good not you know the classic
like pulling people in which your chains
always enjoyable although I don't know
if this is the variation of his that has
that
I think this is one of their custom
variations
I like the thematics theme they picked a
white outfit good branding going on yeah
like see all those teleport strings
they're like pretty good pretty easy to
do
and the fact that he hasn't caught she's
the lack he has a move that helps him
get out of like the corner which is
pretty great and then the three head
strings starting from a low really
really good really all right geez
yeah I've been so cool even as when
screen is so cool yeah I would recommend
if anybody's just starting out and m'kay
try like either a scorpion or sub-zero
yeah both of those are good reliables
they're like the Ken and Ryu of this
game kind of but not really
alright who else in here who said look
at the homies in here got like nine
minutes left of the stream we could uh
we could redo zel yeah he was cool what
up Zell
come play us for the final match of the
stream as all subscribe Ian's for nubs
yeah that's why I was using it because I
don't know how to play this game and any
character who can make that process
easier for me I'm down oh my god I can
hear the echo my voice in your screen
and I hate it
[Music]
lord save me I'm not really that good
it's I can't either
I just know like a combo or two that's
how delete our stream is though GG's
great scorpion play my friend sang spit
out and Oh a heck of an outfit yeah I
like it
Oh God gives him a lex luger look
Oh a counter I like it Oh best game the
skull girlfriend I mean I do love me
some spell girls but marble always holds
a special special place my god I miss it
again no Zowie no I'm a marble player
all I wanna do is jump oh whoa I went
through I can't grab whoa is that
counter it counties everything that's
pretty good
look he Cana was supposed to be my
character is it is that what you're
telling me
I love characters who have counters just
saying characters with counters are dope
I got play Wesker and Marvel and he is
like a projectile counter a high counter
and a low counter so if you're really
feeling yourself that day you're making
all the right read that's cool though Oh
oh wow you just can't mutual jumping I
haven't seen much of like tournament
uh-oh his parry losses to lows and jump
attacks interesting okay make sense I
suppose
I
yeah I got around let's go I'm shook a
bouquet no right out of hand
sannen overhead I'm like I don't even
know that was great
alright good games my friend fantastic
thank you that was premeditation that
was good stuff have a good one
nice yeah that was good and I I'm always
a fan of seeing some brutalities because
if you guys don't know to actually get
like a brutality to happen you have to
meet all these crazy-ass requirements
just for it happened and it's it's wild
so I always appreciate getting to see
one so thank you so good games good
games everybody else you tuned in and
for those of you celebrating turkey day
Happy Holidays get fat eat lots of food
it's winter you need to stock up on you
know body fat and all that good stuff so
have fun have a great weekend we'll see
you guys next week peace out
[Music]